- So speaking of supernatural,
you do tarot card readings, do you?
- I do, I do.
- I am into this as well and
it kills me that literally,
like every time I've
done it, it's dead on.
- I know. It pretty much always is.
It's really creepy.
- Crazy.
- Yeah, but isn't it one of those things
that you can sort of adjust?
It's like, when they read
your horoscope for the day.
You can read any of those-
- You can't see what you want.
- And you could apply
it to whatever yours is.
- You can.
- You would. Yeah.
- But when I say like dead
on, I mean like literally-
- Yeah.
- What I was talking about-
- Exactly.
- Like last night.
Okay, well Josh and I pulled
some cards this morning.
I was very excited. Maybe Josh wasn't.
- No, he was.
- No, I'm-
- No, he was great.
- Can you tell us what they mean?
- Can I get the cards?
So sorry.
- I remember mine.
- Okay. All right, so.
- Yeah.
- Yours were-
You got the Three of Cups.
- Yeah.
- And then you also got, this
isn't a card trick, I swear.
And then you also got Judgement-
- Yep.
- And Hanged Man.
- And this makes a lot like, okay,
so, the Three of Cups is like
collaborative experiences
with platonic people in your life.
Women.
Usually for me, it's women.
- Yeah.
- Like real celebrations of
friendship and support and love.
And then you got Judgement
and The Hanged Man
which are big cards.
So, good cards.
But it feels like you're maybe
at the end of sort of a cycle.
And Judgement is very much
like allowing change to happen.
But don't push change.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Like sit with it, allow it.
- Okay.
- And then The Hanged
Man to get that after,
that's like, you're
gonna be in a situation
that maybe feels uncomfortable
because it's like meditative
but you just have to
sit in the discomfort.
And like, on the other side is growth
and like so much knowledge and-
Does this feel accurate?
- Like, insane.
(audience laughs)
- Does it feel
accurate to you?
- It's insane.
- Okay. Yay.